and welcome to hannity this busy news
friday night uh by the way joe biden
he's already off to delaware for his
weekend of ice cream and sleep and oh i
don't know maybe a couple of medical
checks but back at the white house his
presidency is imploding his approval
numbers are crashing and you we the
american people were all suffering and
it's getting so bad that it sounds like
well circle back gensake is jumping ship
we'll have the very latest coming up
tonight but first with the worsening
crisis both at home and abroad democrats
and their media mob allies they're
desperate to distract you in any way
they possibly can and desperate to gin
up more phony outrage and more lies to
push their far left extremist agenda
because tonight the left-wing rage mob
along with the disney corporation
they're now continuing to spew lies
about florida's new parental rights law
so we will do what the mob and the media
won't do we'll tell you the truth we'll
break it down we'll tell you what's in
the law and what's not in the law now
the law's real name is the parental
rights and education act now it's not
the don't say gay bill as the media
claims
it bans school employees or third
parties from giving classroom
instruction on sexual orientation or
gender identity in pre-k kindergarten
through third grade
that's it the law also bolsters the
ability of parents to know what is being
taught in their children's class it
gives parents a course of action when
teachers cross that line
and that's pretty much it but for
whatever reason democrats they are
enraged over protection for parents and
continue to falsely claim that this law
bans the use of the word gay which it
certainly does not but apparently eager
to jump on the far left bandwagon well
the disney corporation their woke
employees they're in a complete meltdown
disney released a statement outright
lying about the law calling it the don't
say gay law
employees recently staged the walkout
and now disney says that they're gonna
ban boys and girls and and greetings at
the park like for example ladies and
gentlemen boys and girls children of all
ages we can't say that anymore
of course like clockwork the whole saga
is exposing yet more rampant hypocrisy
inside of woke corporate america because
get this we are now learning tonight
that disney to their credit of their
capitalist you know company they're
expanding their streaming operation into
10 countries
oh algeria egypt libya morocco and many
others
what do those countries and others have
in common
they criminalize
homosexuality and have very strict
anti-gay laws and by the way disney has
a problem with florida keeping sex ed
out of kindergarten but is apparently
unbothered by
anti-gay uh persecution abroad they're
gonna have to answer for that and now
florida governor ron desantis he is
rightly standing up against all of the
far left lunacy all the lies being told
and floating a repeal of disney's
so-called self-governing status under
florida law it dates back to 1967
and here's governor desantis explaining
it earlier today take a look well over
many many decades brian they've gotten
incredible treatment from the florida
legislature and they are treated on a
pedestal this one corporation is treated
differently than everybody else and so
that's not something i've ever supported
but now in the legislature you see a
movement to reevaluate those special
privileges and so at the end of the day
i think disney has gotten over its skis
on this
as as it stands now disney joyce white
autonomy in running their disney park
with little to no government oversight
over
a 25 000 acre area in florida who else
in florida has that deal for example
disney has full control over their
entire infrastructure they can levy
their own taxes and tolls and fees on
users with complete authority they don't
need the permission of the state they
also have eminent domain power they have
the power to issue bonds the power to
build nuclear power plants really and
disney is exempt from state and local
zoning laws and so much more now why
does disney enjoy these massive benefits
and if this is how they're going to act
why should they keep them
especially if they're going to lie about
a law that doesn't exist the way they
say it exists
now while republicans and common sense
americans all across the country are
committed to standing up for students
and parents you have these far left
corporations extreme democrats they're
all hell-bent on undermining the dignity
of education no matter what it is
far-left activism is now at the center
of our major corporations as they now
work to turn their business models into
left-wing propaganda centers now
everyday americans are standing strong
they'd like to have a say in their kids
education
many are now calling out disney for this
far left lunacy as one mother writes in
a piece for foxnews.com quote for those
who love the magic of disney as children
and have seen the wonder in our
children's eyes disney world it is
disconcerting to see the company that
animated our childhoods and now our
children's childhood slowly becoming
more progressive and floridians they
appear to be siding with the governor
with a brand new poll showing desantis
at nearly 60 percent approval rating but
joey biden far left democrats they're
siding with the radical activists the
woe corporations over the legitimate
concerns of parents and students and
they're spewing lies and stoking more
division and fueling rage all while the
destructive democratic agenda fails on
pretty much every single front hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else